i i must say that in listening to the
lectures so far and then reading some of
her work again
that uh it strikes me that more than
most in these uh in this discipline
she brings
a real respect for all points of view uh
and an even-handed treatment
even as she
brings her cogent criticism to the to
the topic
um and uh i must say that as other uh uh
people have commented her writing is uh
clear concise and to the point and uh
and uh she like i think that language is
really crucial in
our study and our thinking and we can't
get away from thinking about language
when we think about clear thought
well it's a real pleasure today to
introduce professor ernstein smith for
her third lecture entitled deep readings
the new natural theology
thanks very much bill nice to see you
all again
hello
my aim in these lectures
indicated a bit obliquely in my title
is to examine science religion and human
cognition
at some of their currently interesting
intellectual junctures
and to indicate thereby
some features of each that are i think
mutually and generally illuminating
the nexus points
include contemporary efforts to explain
various aspects of religion especially
their origins and persistence by way of
cognitive science and evolutionary
psychology
a project that i examined last week
under the rubric of the new naturalism
another such point my focus today
is what i'm calling here the new natural
theology
that is current efforts by
scientifically knowledgeable theologians
and some theologically inclined
scientists
to demonstrate the cognitive consonance
between the accounts of nature given in
the natural sciences and traditional
christian beliefs
examples of the latter efforts include a
book by quantum physicist anglican
priest john polkinghorn titled exploring
reality the intertwining of science and
religion
the recent book by paleontologist simon
conway morris titled life's solution
inevitable humans in a lonely universe
which doesn't sound as if it's that
theological but it is
and of particular interest here a much
cited book by theologian john hawt
titled deeper than darwin the prospect
for religion in the age of evolution
the two general projects i just
mentioned one the naturalizing of
religion the other the theologizing of
natural science could be seen as mirror
images of each other natural reflections
in that sense
additionally as i hope to indicate here
they both reflect in their various
elaborations some more general natural
or at least recurrent and perhaps
inevitable features of human cognition
the sort of efforts i'll be looking at
today attempts as it is said to
reconcile science and religion have a
history as long as the independent
existence of each
because of course they weren't always
separate
granted that long history i should note
some important differences between what
i'm calling here the new natural
theology understood as contemporary
attempts
of that kind
and older more familiar versions of
natural theology so named
traditional natural theology anticipated
by aristotle
articulated by augustine pursued by
thomas aquinas
elaborated most influentially under that
name by william paley in the early 19th
century
and rehearsed in our own time by
proponents of so-called intelligent
design
seeks and claims to find evidence in
reason or nature alone as distinct from
scripture or revelation for the
existence and attributes of a supreme
being
in contrast the aims and claims of the
new natural theology
are subtler and more modest but also by
the same token more equivocal and
elusive
thus john haught in his book deeper than
darwin
accepts without reservation the accounts
of nature framed in contemporary
evolutionary science
but scrutinizes them the word is his
for other meanings
seeking not evidence of but merely room
for a providential deity
not proof of redemption but possibly
legible signs of a surprising future
not grounds for believing in personal
immortality but reason to hope for the
fulfillment of what we intuit as a
certain promise these are all quotes
here is elsewhere in the new natural
theology scholastic logic and
traditional hermeneutics that is methods
of interpretation are supplemented by
more contemporary modes of deep reading
while confident displays of theistic
triumphalism are replaced by the
ambiguous gestures of theological
scientific compatibilism
there are a number of points of interest
for us here but first a brief review of
some of these features as illustrated in
hort's book
one such simultaneously conceptual and
rhetorical is the interweaving of idioms
specifically hort here like polkinghorn
conway morris and others working in this
genre
operates with a sort of macaronic that
is combined vernacular and learned style
that deploys the technical terms of
contemporary natural science either in
smooth conjunction with elements of a
more familiar religious idiom for
example scriptural liturgical or
homiletic
or with an expressly theological spin
thus in a typical formulation hort
writes quote
the divine fidelity to promise is
embedded in and creatively working
through
the laws of nature and is the novelty
that breaks in through the accidental
end quote
or in another passage mixing familiar
terms from linguistics with specifically
christian concepts
quote
nature's predictable laws can be read as
necessary grammatical rules that any
incarnation of deeper meaning must
adhere to if it is to receive embodiment
or a bit later invoking the technical
term deep time from geology
quote
from a theological perspective
deep time may be thought of as the
consequence of god's opening up the
world to a luxuriantly creative future
in these examples and more generally the
resulting terms of phrase are often
imaginative and evocative but can also
be for at least some readers
conceptually thorny and or just plain
peculiar sounding
another feature of the new natural
theology though itself far from new
is allegory a central device of
classical hermeneutics based on the idea
that a particular text whether book of
god
book of nature or book of mortal author
declares its messages otherwise and
requires oblique and expansive reading
the idea in other words that what
something means most importantly is
different from what it means when
understood as it is said literally
conventionally or in hawth's preferred
term shallowly
the possibility of concurrent literal
and allegorical shallow and deep
naturalistic and theological
understandings of natural phenomena
the cosmological big bang the evolution
of living forms the so-called anthropic
principle and so forth
is a key assumption of the new natural
theology
the possibility of such concurrent
understandings naturalistic and
traditionally the theistic of religious
phenomena
is an ongoing dis is an issue in ongoing
disputes between proponents of the new
naturalist accounts of religion daniel
dennett richard dawkins and others and
their theistic critics
the question in the latter case is
whether if one grants that religious
beliefs and behavior are in some
respects natural phenomena
as dennett claims in the subtitle of his
book breaking the spell
meaning here the products of evolved
cognitive mechanisms whether they cannot
also be the sign and expression of
things higher deeper or at least more
interesting
thus as we'll see in the second part of
today's lecture
while hot and other theologians commonly
acknowledge the possibility of
naturalistic accounts of some features
of religion they vigorously dispute the
idea such as is maintained by new
naturalists like
pascal boyer that those accounts
theologians like hort acknowledge the
possibility of naturalistic explanations
of some features of religion but they
dispute the idea that those accounts
give exclusively valid explanations of
religious beliefs and practices it's a
matter of whether it's concurrent or
exclusive so
this brings us to a third form of
negotiation between scientific knowledge
and religious doctrine
in
the new natural theology
namely the idea that i've already
mentioned that room is left for theistic
postulates in the accounts of nature
offered by the sciences
for example in quantum and chaos theory
for poking horn in paleontology and
cosmology for conway morris and in
evolutionary theory for heart
hart writes quote
the theory of evolution leaves many
questions unanswered
and even a thicker scientific account
will still leave abundant room for
theological readings as well
as hot explains this the fact that the
combination of chemicals that gave rise
to life were novel
that the origin of life was spontaneous
and that mutations responsible for
genetic variation are random
together suggests that certain events
are outside the laws of nature that
there are some things that are not
natural and for which the laws of nature
equated here with exact repetition and
strictly deterministic processes
must allow room
there is however no non-theological
reason to think that what are referred
to as novelty spontaneity and randomness
in the relevant scientific accounts are
not themselves natural phenomena
it is only when the regularities
observed in nature are conceived as
prior fixed and uniform laws
that phenomena must in some sense obey
in effect that the so-called laws of
nature have autonomous normative
authority
that what scientists characterize as
novel random or spontaneous events can
be read as signs of extra natural
activity
suggesting
inviting or as in more familiar
intelligent design arguments requiring
more aggressively than leaving room for
theological explanation
in terms of providential creation
similarly in passages i'll quote in a
moment what conceives contingency
as if it were an autonomic
autonomous cosmic force and not just a
way of referring to the routine
dependence of particular events on the
existence of particular sets of
conditions
i want to return however to the notion
of room being left or not
for theological interpretations of
natural science findings
the phrase suggests a more general
conception of intellectual activity as
occurring in a finite space where rival
accounts jostle against one another for
limited quarters and as in hort's book
and elsewhere spar over which is deeper
than the other
this spatialized competitive conception
of the relation among alternative ideas
is recurrent and ubiquit ubiquitous
found among scientists and philosophers
as well as theologians
there's some question however as to
whether it's an especially good way to
represent either individual cognitive
activity or the dynamics of intellectual
history
or conversely whether that ultimately
claustrophobic conception doesn't foster
the very intellectual anxieties that its
invocation seeks to escape
this question emerges at various points
in deeper than darwin
what's major argument in the book or
rather his suggestion the style is
conscientiously diffident can be
summarized as follows i'm giving my
summary then i'll give his
statement of the same point the account
of evolution in darwinian theory
constitutes a narrative
the unfolding of which requires the
prior assembly and continuous operation
of three crucial ingredients namely
contingency invariance and deep time
the story again this is my summary of
hort's mark argument the storyline
unfolds in such a way that its
protagonist life undergoes a series of
transformations over a long period of
time
finally manifesting itself as humanity
in the very manner of its unfolding that
is through the ongoing operations of
contingency invariance and deep time
the narrative foretells that we humanity
or maybe just some of us it's left vague
in hort's text
will after another perhaps long period
of time and undergoing further
transformations arrive finally at quote
the destiny promised to us
presumably by scripture and christian
tradition though the source and the
destiny are also left vague
rehearsing and commenting on this
argument hort writes and this is now a
long quote from him
nature has revealed itself as an immense
story
and this story in turn may very well be
open to many levels of reading
to be perfectly clear here darwinism
presupposes
since by itself it cannot account for
the narrative cosmic tablet on which the
life story becomes inscribed
or to put it in other terms our three
background ingredients that is
contingency in variance and deep time
must be waiting on the cosmic table
long before the darwinian process begins
mixing and cooking them
neither darwinian science nor any of the
other sciences can satisfactorily tell
us why nature is constituted in just
such a way as to allow the universe to
unfold narratively
the question invites theological comment
of course it could be purely accidental
but the question is why any story at all
the point is
we cannot help embedding all of our
speculation within a narrative a priori
in accordance with which
evolution has forged our brains end
quote
several features of this passage along
with their combined effect are worth
noting
one is the joining of expressions of
intellectual tentativeness as in the
story may very well be open to many
levels of breeding or of course it could
be purely accidental
with what are represented as logical
ontological or psychological necessities
as in
darwinism
presupposes must be waiting on the
cosmic table or
we cannot help embedding
another feature is what i referred to
earlier as the characteristic weaving
together of the neutral descriptive
language of science evolution the
darwinian process nature is constituted
and so forth and the rhetorically
heightened metaphoric oblique and
archaic language of theological doctrine
nature has revealed itself
the cosmic tablets
the life story becomes inscribed and so
forth
taken jointly these features give a
sense of combined
scientific weight
objective necessity
and religious resonance to what might
otherwise be seen as a series of
gratuitous inferences somewhat tenuously
strung together and indeed the book is a
powerful
work rhetorically and quite poetic and
has a large following and
is
a formidable um
structure to deal with
at the conclusion of his deep reading of
evolutionary theory
hought suggests that it was the
providential author of the story of life
who arranged for evolution to construct
our brains so that we or at least those
of us duly prepared
cannot help but
make out
that very story in nature he sums up the
argument and suggestion as follows quote
when we read the universe with eyes and
ears prepared by the motif of promise
there emerges a palpable consonants
between the narrative character of a
life-bearing evolutionary cosmos on the
one hand and the general thrust of
religious hope on the other end quote
in other words
when we read the universe with eyes and
ears prepared by convictions of
providence and redemption
the universe tells us stories of
to minds so primed
there emerges a palpable consonants
between the book of nature as read by
science and the book of god as read by
the religiously inspired or instructed
hort wants to suggest of course that
this emergent consonance is
wants to suggest is evidence of god's
hand in the evolution of both the
natural world and the minds or brains of
creatures ourselves who perceive it
but his conclusion here could also be
seen as an implicit acknowledgement of
the hermeneutic circularity at the heart
of the new natural theology one finds
what one already has
what is revealed is what one already
knows
and a pretty good description of the
cognitive mechanisms by which such
circularity operates
for better and for worse
in theology and elsewhere including
science itself
i have
made
i have dealt with that last point at
some length in
my last two books
scandalous knowledge and belief and
resistance
hort's reading of science's reading of
nature will be cognitively agreeable to
those who come prepared to believe it
largely those for whom the major
elements connections and characteristic
idiom of christian belief are not only
intimately familiar
but who operate with those elements
every day conceptually
perceptually emotionally
pragmatically
socially and of course verbally
to those however who do not come to such
a reading so prepared
who operate every day in all these ways
with different beliefs and different
idioms i do not say no beliefs or of
course no idioms
hort's book and comparable works of new
natural theology
will sound not or not necessarily wrong
or foolish but to repeat the term that i
used a moment ago
gratuitous
a matter not of deep meanings truly
revealed but of interpretations
ingeniously constructed
interpretations that one may take or
leave accept or reject
depending on one's prior intellectual
dispositions
individual cognitive tastes and perhaps
individual cognitive needs
we can put this gratuitousness the other
way around
nothing in logic nature or science
prevents anyone from giving theistic
glosses either to observe natural
phenomena
or to such scientific concepts as
randomness spontaneity or invariance
but equally
nothing in logic
nature or science
requires anyone to give such glosses
the theological deep readings allegories
interpretations
ways of seeing nature ways of putting
together the world
ontologies
remain optional
matters of subjective imaginative
possibility
not logical or any other kind of
objective necessity
including the satisfaction of any
allegedly universal spiritual needs
which hot uh invokes
or for that matter
the automatic operation of any allegedly
universal cognitive mechanisms
we're not obliged to think theistically
that's my point not from
a psychological necessity
or
from a psychological necessity
theistically interpreted or a
psychological necessity naturalistically
interpreted
if the inevitability and irreducibility
of this disparity of response that is
two ways of reading deep readings
is granted
then clearly the new theological
readings of nature cannot claim to offer
transcendental objective non-contingent
truth
and in fact neither hort nor the new
natural theologians more generally make
such objectivist claims for their
readings
rather the interpretations remain and in
a way are tacitly understood by all
concerned as posits
notions conceits
expressions of ways of thinking
manifestations of assumptions and
attitudes
webs of connections idioms of
articulation
other
non-theological or differently
theological readings of the universe for
example atheistic
pantheistic or polytheistic remain
logically cognitively and historically
possible
or we could say
room is left
for these alternative ontologies in
intellectual space-time
a realm that is not i would suggest
finite or cramped
but for humans generally and for each of
us individually
essentially and perhaps infinitely
elastic
of course the question may be raised as
to whether such truth that is
non-contingent exclusively proper and
objectively deepest can be claimed for
the readings of the natural universe
offered by evolutionary or any other
science including especially relevantly
here the readings or explanations of
human nature
offered by evolutionary
psychology and this brings us to the
second part of today's lecture in which
that question is raised with some energy
by hot here in company with other
theistic critics of the new naturalist
accounts of religion
in a central chapter of deeper than
darwin
hot attempts to undercut evolutionary
psychologists who claim foundational
status for their theories of religion
and of human nature more generally
the term undercut with its suggestion of
undoing from below
is especially apt here since a good part
of the issue for both sides that is
theological and naturalistic
is relative epistemic rank as marked by
comparative depth in effect the lower
the depth the higher the rank
thus john tube and leda cosmetics titled
their major theoretical work the
psychological foundations of culture and
like other evolutionary psychologists
are quite explicit or indeed aggressive
in claiming epistemic priority and
primacy for their accounts of human
behavior by way of innate mental
mechanisms
cutting across the spatial metaphors
that is of depth
is a series of other distinctions that
tend to get conflated with them and with
each other in the course of the mutual
critiques
accordingly some brief remarks on
terminology are required
in everyday discourse we often
distinguish deep explanations from
superficial ones usually meaning those
that get at crucial and important causes
rather than just incidental or minor
ones
in scholastic philosophy explanations
are often distinguished on the basis of
whether they involve primary causes
usually god or only such secondary
causes as material physical mechanisms
or following aristotle whether they
identify final causes meaning purposes
man's or again gods or only so-called
efficient material or formal causes
in modern biology a quite different
non-hierarchical distinction is drawn
between ultimate causes and proximate
ones where ultimate means
what happened
over time evolved
and proximate means operating physically
or physiologically
thus when a biologist refers to an
explanation of some human trait say a
dread of snakes
as ultimate he or she is not or not
necessarily saying that it's the final
or most basic explanation but rather
that it identifies the fitness enhancing
functions for which the trait was
presumably naturally selected here
predator avoidance rather than the
physiological mechanisms that are
observed to produce it here say
adrenaline releasing mechanisms
as it happens hot conflates these quite
different sets of distinctions
throughout deeper than darwin while also
as we've already seen characterizing
theological accounts of natural
phenomena as their deepest explanations
that's objectionable of course but it
must be added that the conflations in
question are partly enabled by the
overreaching or we should say here under
reaching claims of evolutionary
psychologists themselves who often refer
to their accounts not only as providing
foundations for the study of human
behavior and culture but also as
revealing the ultimate causes of such
phenomena in the sense of the most
significant and crucial ones and for
whom depth also marks the primary locus
of causal efficacy
we recall the mental basements of pascal
boyer's book religion explained were all
the causal cognitive mechanisms were
said to be located
all the familiar deep structures of
chomsky and language theory echoed in
lawson and mccauley's theory of ritual
in their book rethinking religion
these conflations are further enabled by
the fact that many evolutionary
theorists biologists and philosophers as
well as evolutionary psychologists
share with hot and other theologians not
only a classic surface depth model of
appearance and reality
what's low is what's real
what's out on the surface is mere
appearance
but also an evidently
widespread human tendency
which the new naturalists stress but not
in reference to their own practices
a widespread tendency to understand and
represent complex naturally occurring
phenomena as the purposive acts of
powerful agents
a controlling providential deity in the
case of the theologians
and in the case of the evolutionary
theorists a controlling genome or a
providential natural selection or indeed
for many of them a powerful and
providential if sometimes quirky mother
nature
these latter reifying animistic
anthropomorphic and purposive concepts
are commonly described by the
evolutionary theorists who use them as
mere metaphors and defend it as shortcut
ways of speaking but they are pervasive
in scientific discourse and their
operations can have significant and
often quite dubious intellectual
consequences
as we'll see in a minute
i want to turn now to hort's extended
critique of what he calls the new
darwinian accounts of religion which
corresponds closely to what i've been
calling here and spoke of last week as
the new naturalism what sites centrally
for example boyer's religion explained
and walter burkitt's creation of the
sacred both of which i discussed last
week
the new darwinians thought rites explain
the persistence of god without assuming
the effects of the real presence of
god's end quote
that of course is correct doing without
theistic assumptions is what defines a
natural explanation of anything from the
structure of the cosmos to the
adaptiveness of life forms
and it may be for some fundamentalist
theists an objectionable feature of all
science for that very reason
but the collision with theistic
assumptions becomes especially acute
even for non-fundamentalists like hot in
the case of explanations of the gods
themselves
as indicated by his phrasing which
suggests that there's something perverse
in the new darwinians ignoring quote the
effects of the real presence of god's
end quote
thus he writes a bit later
to naturalize means in this instance to
ask what we can make of religion by
ignoring what religious people
themselves would identify as its
ultimate explanation and all the
meanings of ultimate are in play there
end quote
the acuteness of the collision of
assumptions here is also reflected i
think in the i'm sorry to say
exaggeration misunderstanding
and kind of sour sarcasm that recur
among theistic commentaries on the new
naturalist accounts of religion
thus what continues
all of the characteristics we associate
with religion its rituals doctrines
stories institutions and theologies are
fully understandable then if we read
them as having had an adaptive function
end quote
but this is a considerable overstatement
even of boyer's often chest thumping
claims
as we've seen what the new darwinians
typically maintain is that many features
of religion not all can be understood as
products or byproducts of cognitive
mechanisms that were adaptive
not as having had an adaptive function
themselves
moreover at their best or most
responsible or most chastened the new
naturalists even dennett acknowledge the
need to supplement darwinian
understandings of religion with other
accounts for example in their case
historical studies
reiterating his main point hort writes
darwinian analysis allows anthropology
to conclude that religion beneath its
complex surface manifestations was
ultimately invented by our genes as an
adaptive contrivance in berkert's
understanding
gods persist because our genes need to
persist end quote
two points uh to be made here
first the force of hot's observation
draws on his running conflation of the
technical meaning of ultimate as a
matter of naturally selected functions
with its vernacular meaning as that
which is most fundamental
the effect is to make any evolutionary
explanation sound like a claim of
epistemic primacy
which it sometimes is but isn't always
second although burkitt who i discussed
last time does invoke richard dawkins
notion of selfish genes in passages that
i didn't discuss he does not explain the
persistence of gods by gene's need to
persist
hot however seems to think the latter
idea is implied by dawkins popular
metaphor for gene level selection
thus hort writes a bit later for some
unspecified reason so the argument goes
genes have an inherent need to survive
into the next generation end quote
but there is nothing unspecified either
vague or glossed over as this seems to
imply in the argument that genes survive
only when the organisms whose traits
they specify survive and reproduce
and no evolutionary theorists not even
dawkins would endorse the claim that
this occurs because genes have needs
inherent or otherwise
but
dot hot's misunderstandings here are
certainly enabled by dawkins dramatic
anthropomorphism
which though only metaphoric can as i
suggested earlier have unfortunate
effects
what's misreading of dawkins view of
gene selection
central to his objections to the new
darwinian accounts of religion
may help illuminate the often
exceedingly unhappy angry or caustic
responses of other theistic critics of
the new naturalism
we recall that darwin himself in a
celebrated passage at the end of the
origin of species saw quote a kind of
grandeur
in the implicitly de-theologized
creation story
he had just laid out
it's an epic or indeed biblical grandeur
that hot attempts to retain for
christians by re-theologizing the
darwinian account and merging it with
various strands of christian idiom and
belief
one can see how for an imaginative
reader like hot
the insistently naturalistic and a
hyphen theistic non-theistic but also
mock teleological
retelling of the same darwinian creation
tale by dawkins
this time with genes not an
anthropomorphized mother nature or even
a mighty natural selection as the main
agents
he might re might read to him like a
particularly nasty version of wagner's
twilight of the gods
with control over life forms transformed
excuse me transferred from an exalted
providential deity to a gang of greedy
conniving little nibelongan working away
underground or indeed and more
disagreeably working way down within
each of us
the picture of the universe that emerges
from what dawkins and following him
dennett call darwinian thinking
is not merely of no god no soul and
nature read in truth and tooth and claw
but of every feature of every creature
bird tree squirrel and strawberry one's
child one's lover and one's own self as
being top to toe
inside and out the way it is only
because better enabling the survival and
reproduction of the gene that specifies
it
or at best being biologically carried
along by such a function
it is to say the least a disconcerting
image and one can almost sense the host
of cognitive mechanisms
that rush in supplying other knowledge
or alternative conceptualizations to
restore an image of the living world and
of our own selves that is more in accord
with familiar orientations
thus we may remind ourselves
that even though our structures and
fundamental modes of operation
have been shaped by natural selection
not everything we do as particular human
beings involves furthering our strictly
biological benefit or the benefit of our
genes
we may also remind ourselves that as
continuously developing and cognitively
adapting creatures
we are affected over the course of our
lifetimes by our particular experiences
which shape our thoughts purposes
judgments and actions and indeed our
bodies top to toe inside and out
throughout our lives and arguably no
less profoundly than any genetic
specification or innate wiring
theists typically give such
self-reminders a theological twist
we are not mere animals or mere bodies
or mere machines
we have god-given souls and god-given
reason
that's the way one reviewer replies to
dawkins
last book a devil's chaplain
but such self-redeeming and of course
classically humanistic ideas can also be
understood strictly naturalistically
we have good reason to maintain from the
work of cognitive science
that seemed all right do you want to see
whether that's a dramatic performance or
someone in some trouble
so i was speaking of the way in which
the rather disconcerting image presented
um by
darwinian thinking
can be
interpreted
in such a way as we remind ourselves of
the various ways in which
that particular darwinian picture
although not untrue does not describe
the way in which we
develop individually the way in which we
uh think and make our
choices when seen from a different
perspective then i say
this reminding can be given two forms
theists can say it's because of our
god-given soul but then i am going on
and saying but
even those reminders can themselves be
naturalistic
we have good reason to maintain that
certain of our cognitive faculties are
more highly developed and subtly
responsive than those of other animals
and as evolutionary theorists
increasingly acknowledge the natural
environments even the humblest into
which human beings are born and in which
they develop are significantly
culturally verbally and socially
enriched and as one such theorist puts
it epistemically engineered that is this
an awful lot of stuff around libraries
texts and so forth that
give us knowledge and allow us to
hone the way we think the way we make
judgments
by virtue of the discriminations
foresights
counterfactual imaginings and other
complex responses enabled by cognitive
faculties so shaped and so developed
our thoughts judgments and actions can
and often do
override as it said our more primitive
impulses and intuitive responses
though of course the overriding can also
run in the other direction
to return however to hort's criticisms
he continues
quote a usually unspoken but clearly
operative postulate in this new
darwinian interpretation of religion is
a quite modern one
religions provided illusory but
effective shields against the terrors of
existence
and by favoring our species with the
fictitious phantasm of a purposeful
universe religions gave our human
predecessors a reason to keep on living
to bear offspring and thus keep their
genes from perishing end quote
but this i mean you can hear the sarcasm
this is inaccurate in a number of
respects
first the idea that religious myths
assuage the terrors of existence is not
modern it was advanced by among others
lucretius in the first century bc and by
david hume famously in the natural
history of religion
second thought again mistakes the
mis-states the logic and main contention
of the new darwinian accounts of
religion
the claim is not that religious ideas of
among other things a purposeful universe
were themselves adaptive
but that such ideas are recurrently
produced by species wide and thus
presumably naturally selected because
fitness enhancing cognitive mechanisms
third
contributes to fitness does not mean is
crucial to survival
and no new naturalist to my knowledge
has suggested that without religious
ideas our ancestors would have all
perished
what may be thinking here of a passage
from burkitt's creation of the sacred
where reflecting on the centrality of
gift exchange in ancient societies
burkitt suggests that its basic
principle give that you may be given in
return in effect due unto others
was also reflected in ancient religions
this is now from birker quote
the principle of reciprocity is not only
a widely successful social strategy but
a postulate acted out to create a stable
sensible and acceptable world
gratifying both intellectually and
morally and bridging the gap of
annihilation that is to death
thus teaching and rehearsing such
strategies has prevailed in religious
tradition
life is bound to optimism even this may
be called a biological necessity end
quote
but if this is the sort of observation
hort has in mind
then his paraphrase of it as the claim
that by favoring our species with the
fictitious phantom of a purposeful
universe religions gave our human
predecessors a reason to keep their
genes from perishing end quote
transforms an urbane but sympathetic
reflection into a piece of raw
biological reductionism which is
certainly is not in
burkitt's book
what we encounter here in hawt's acerbic
characterizations of burkitt
and incomparably caustic and distorting
reviews of works by boyer atrin and
other new naturalists which as you heard
last week i think can be criticized on
many grounds and are limited in many
methodological and intellectual
conceptual ways but nevertheless that's
different from a
um sort of as i say sour and
misunderstanding review
by various theological minded academics
and religiously invested journalists
so these characterizations this way of
handling the new naturalism is a sign i
think
not merely of a sharp divergence of what
we call rather abstractly intellectual
positions but of a more radically
intense and personally implicating
experience
it's called classically cognitive
dissonance
that is
the sense
simultaneously psychic and bodily
of disruption alarm anger or revulsion
at what we experience as something
deeply amiss
contrary to the way things are and the
way they should be
the experience of cognitive dissonance
which can be elicited by wrong-seeming
sensory percepts as well as
intellectually disturbing ideas clashing
sounds or colors
the sudden glimpse of a badly disfigured
person and so forth
was identified by that term half a
century ago
and characterized at the times by leon
fessinger for those of you who remember
the history of it
characterized as a major motive in human
behavior
in our efforts to relieve or escape the
sense of acute cognitive disorder that
defines it we may seek to eliminate the
discordant percept itself
sometimes by fleeing it
sometimes by covering or removing it
and sometimes by trying to destroy it
or more happily for all concerned by
assimilating it into our cognitive
repertoire and adjusting accordingly our
sense of what is and what is possible in
the universe so that the primitive
mechanism is neutralized
the operations of cognitive dissonance
can be readily discerned i believe in
the history of social including
religious conflict and persecution
and also as i have argued elsewhere in
academic controversy and intellectual
history including the history of science
scientists too experience cognitive
dissonance and react to it
by fleeing it
by forgetting it by obscuring it
but
if science is operating as it does at
its maximum best then the discordant
percept the anomaly gets
put into
the structure of the universe and stops
being an anomaly and reshapes what it is
that we understand that the universe
consists of
in any case it's clear that the
occasions dynamics and behavioral
consequences of this pervasive cognitive
phenomenon
deserve the attention of contemporary
cognitive theorists including or
especially those concerned with the
relations between science and religion
to return however to hawth's criticisms
having concluded unhappily and i think
erroneously that darwinian accounts of
our religious ideas render them simply
false he writes quote
they are pure this is i mean this
everything is ironic they are pure
fictions and lovers of truth should be
willing to give them up as apparently
the new darwinian debunkers of religion
have done themselves or never had such
ideas
however while they claim to be in
possession of the final truth about
religion
they are not terribly disturbed as were
earlier critics of religion that most of
humanity wallows in the essentially
false comforts of religion end quote
indeed hot adds the earlier critics
would have found this new view that is
the darwinians allegedly blase attitude
toward the benighted state of most
humanity
highly objectionable on moral grounds
end quote
what is of course being doubly caustic
here
suggesting that the earlier naturalistic
critics of religion presumably marx and
freud among others have a moral edge
over the contemporary darwinians
he's thinking here of boyer and burkett
not dennett dawkins or sam harris who
are of course disturbed in just the way
he describes and thinks shows that they
are you know
well i'll go on and say in any case his
point is that those earlier critics at
least put a high value on truth and
human authenticity
while he implies the new debunkers are
not only atheistic but more deeply
cynical
but the point is strained and hot
overlooks a more important and
potentially
genial implication of some of the more
recent efforts to explain religion
to be sure a number of the new
naturalists combine what appear to be a
biologically instructed personally
personal conviction of the holy natural
holy altogether naturalistic springs of
religious devotion
and an historically instructed
observation of the ambivalent value of
such devotion for humans generally for
better or worse you remember
and indeed will appear in the quote that
i'm about to read
but there is nothing cynical about that
conjunction not in my view
thus scott atron writes at the end of
his book in gods we trust quote
for better or worse religious belief in
the supernatural seems here to stay
with it comes trust and deities good and
bad
songs of fellowship and drums of war
promises to allay our worst fears and
achieve our most fervent hopes
and heartfelt communion in costly homage
to the absurd
this loss and gain persist
as the abiding measure of humanity
no other seems able to compete for very
long
and so
spirituality looms as humankind's
provisional evolutionary destiny end
quote
although there's no trace of theistic
profession here atron's comments do not
sound to my ears like cynicism or
condescension toward the generality of
humanity still
wallowing as hot puts it bitterly in the
essentially false comforts of religion
on the contrary
atron's comments seem to me a bit rueful
but also manifestly and sympathetically
humanistic
as for what hot alleges as the new
darwinian's nonchalant attitude toward
truth
it might be said that precisely to the
extent that a scholar like walter
berkert or such other contemporary
scholars of religion as paul vane or
kathryn bell
to precisely to the extent that they do
not share the old critics old positivist
views of knowledge and scientific truth
they are more likely to recognize the
richness and depth indeed of many
religious ideas
practices and experiences
and to appreciate the forms of human
achievement
ingenuity artistry and imagination
involved in their elaboration
toward the conclusion of his attempted
discrediting of current darwinian
accounts of religion
what produces the familiar charge of
self-refutation
commonly elicited from theists by the
common failure of reflexivity on the
part of many new naturalists that is
their failure to consider the
implications of their general accounts
of human cognition for their own beliefs
and practices as scientists
thus hort asks pointedly quote can the
evolutionary psychologist coherently
naturalize human culture which includes
science without sabotaging the authority
of darwinism itself end quote here is
elsewhere
the charge only grazes its target that
is hits it slightly but misses the main
mark
contrary to hort's evident promise
excuse me contrary to hort's evident
premise
the naturalizing of a belief or theory
even one claiming scientific status does
not sabotage its epistemic authority
like many traditionalist philosophers of
science
haute is evidently persuaded that the
authority of scientific knowledge
requires grounding in something
objective or transcendental and
accordingly would be diminished by the
revelation that like other forms of
popular belief including those of
religion
science is crucially shaped by merely
sublunary efforts to survive and
flourish
but the supposedly damaging revelation
about scientific knowledge here can also
be seen as its most solid justification
in other words what gives the cultural
form we call science its epistemic
authority as knowledge is precisely its
demonstrated effectiveness in producing
models of the operations of the physical
world that enable humans to better
survive and flourish in that world
at this point a certain irony may be
clear to members of this audience
familiar with the recent science wars
for it is just that pragmatist and to
some ears deflationary account of
scientific knowledge
that is as human cultural historical
opportunistic and sustained largely by
its practical effectiveness
that has emerged over the past three or
four decades from the naturalistic study
of science in fields such as history and
sociology
the irony here is the close resemblance
of that project that is science studies
which has been deplored and dismissed by
a number of eminent scientists and
philosophers
it's close resemblance to the
naturalistic study of religion a project
that many of those same scientists and
philosophers
certainly dennett pursue applaud and
aggressively promote
the resemblance between the two
naturalizing projects of religion and of
science extends from inspiration and
method in both cases empirical
historical and comparative
to outcome and reception in both cases a
radical challenge
to traditional views of a highly valued
realm of ideas and practices greeted by
widespread misunderstanding
misrepresentation
outrage
and dismissal
a final
word
the absence of reflexivity
on the part of the new naturalists that
is their failure to recognize the ways
in which their cognitive evolutionary
accounts of religious beliefs and
practices
apply to and reflect on their own
beliefs and practices as scientists
exposes them to the theist's charge of
self-refutation
and the taunt of tupue
you too
your science is just as bad or just as
compromised or just as simply natural
and human as you say our religion is
the charge of self-refutation as i
suggested a moment ago is hollow insofar
as it depends on dubious notions of
transcendental foundations
but the taunt of tupway is justified in
indicting the new naturalist's improper
self-exemption
the new naturalist accounts of religion
are not self-refuting
but they are self-ignorant
i'll end there now
and uh next time i'll turn to among
other things efforts by new naturalists
to demonstrate on alleged cognitive
grounds what they see is an all points
contrast between religion and science as
respectively natural that's religion and
unnatural that's science but i'll end
here now thank you
yeah
um as before i need to be able to see
you in order to be able to hear you in
effect so uh would you move the
microphone up if you wish to use this
microphone um
and please identify your field
so i will be able to focus my answer to
you
more precisely
i continue to admire the urgency of your
arguments
in india
in great detail
and
what you see is practically irrefutable
it seems to me it's common sense at the
best
but i have some questions about some of
the characters that appear in this show
for example
my problem
with the new
natural theologians
is in the first place what are they
trying to prove
there are two possibilities
one is
that they are trying to prove
that a fully consistent
biology to stay with this science now
in a truly consistent biology the idea
of god is necessary
the other
possibility is that they are simply
trying to say
biology including the whole theory of
evolution and of neo-darwinism with
mutations
in that theory this theory is not
in conflict with religion this is a very
different story
but it seems to me
that if they are trying
to prove the former jesus namely that
the idea of god
is necessary in biology
then i think they transgress completely
the biological argument
there is nothing in biology
that would lead you to conceive
to let us say a personal god
or an impersonal power
or pantheism or pananthism or for that
matter i think even atheism
the question is this though that if
the theologian says
i want to
believe
no that if he says
the conclusion of my argument is
that there must be something here
then i think he says
something that goes beyond biology then
whatever argument he is making is not a
biological argument
and i i find that problem constantly in
some of the modern natural theology
the second point the biologist on the
other hand
who would exclude
the idea of transcendence up i keep it
neutral altogether
is also making a mistake
because he is actually arguing beyond
this field
more specifically
and more
pedestrianly perhaps
the very fact that he says there is no
problem
or a sudanet would say
oh the mind the whole mind thing is a
survival and state
but this is rather primitive and of
course leads nowhere
if the question that we have to raise i
think is
when biology
is finished
and has done its own work
in such a way
that we do not attack the most
elementary things in my contemporary
biological theory for example to attack
say god is necessary is to attack red in
the biology is from the beginning to
attack the problem of contingency of
mutations
and therefore in my opinion and
therefore i don't think we should attack
that on the other hand if the biologist
says
no this is all
you know amounts to nothing
and there is no problem even in the
problem of mind
then i would say no
that is something of which the biologist
has nothing to say
so in the best case it seems to me that
we would come up
with a solution where the two remain
independent biologically you cannot say
anything about this
and at the same time theologically you
cannot say anything about biology this
should not be taught intelligent design
should not be taught in the biology
class of course
because it even
if it were true it doesn't belong there
it goes beyond biology
i think as you put it
very well in the beginning
there is a question that the biologist
may ask
when everything
like all of us ask when all is said and
done he can say
why is it
that nature has this possibility
is it perhaps possible
that to do contingent elements
elements that are unpredictable even to
god if there is a god
unpredictable that even there
something comes is realized that was
unforeseeable
actually i think the person who raised
the why question was hot that was my uh
quotation of him but i would say that as
last time i find myself in very
considerable agreement with you and i
think the way in which you laid out
those distinctions
is very much in the spirit in which i
myself would like to do it
i agree with you that the you know for
me the crucial point which is why i
insisted on the word gratuitous
was to say it's not necessary it's not
necessary to make this claim it's not
necessary to accept this interpretation
they remain possible and uh as i say the
the space for them in any individual
head and in the history of in
intellectual history is open to
these um formulations which operate in
many different ways
um
i also agree with you and it's going to
be what i start out with next time and
that is
uh all right so you said you you say the
biologist also cannot make ex-claim
about what is and what isn't
the distinction which i know that you
know very well
would be between
methodological naturalism
and metaphysical naturalism i will agree
with you that in making the metaphysical
claim he is making a claim as something
other than a biologist
as for whether he makes the
methodological
move
to suspend any assumption about the
theological
in his biology i'm sure you would agree
that that's
simply a definition of a scientific
practice yes
yes
well i'll disagree with both of you i
think there really is a conflict between
religion and science and
my field is computer science i'm an
expert on everything
uh
the uh
um
and it seems to me that that uh people
like uh polkinghorn whom you didn't
discuss
but i haven't read hot and i have read
horns okay
um
he
spends a lot of time talking about how
it's possible for god to intervene in
the universe and i think this is really
the question that this is the key issue
that if it is not if science
ultimately finds no room for god
to act
then that is a serious
issue and if the only way god can act is
by sneaking around
that's not a very satisfying answer
so much of the
it's both the
you could say the difficulty and the
achievement of the new natural theology
is to
keep difficult questions like that
sort of afloat
so i don't think that hort makes the
kind of
a claim
that
polkinghorn does i find hot subtler and
i find his
use of rhetoric both more compelling as
simply an achievement of the use of
language but also
managing not to expose himself
expose his account to the kind of um
objection that you would raise so he
would the minute you said that would say
that he would step back and say i am not
saying that uh something is
uh there i'm just saying it is there is
room for one to think that there might
be
so
it would be
that sort of move it's
understandable that people i think well
this is um what one is trying to account
for
to understand why it is
that a scientific account that a
knowledgeable theologian such as horde
would
want to continue
to
live a life that he has
developed in
from the time that he was young it's not
a matter of just having a set of beliefs
that he has to
see as
subject to scientific
or even logical
evaluation
it's rather a matter of a whole way of
thinking as i was laying it out it's not
just thinking it's living it's
practicing it's emotional reactions it
is memories it is how one interacts with
many many people around one it is a way
of life
a scientific description
also does other things for him it
accounts for
a way in which he can put together the
world
for certain purposes for what that isn't
all there is to say but i will suggest
next week but i'm sorry next time
um is that there are very few people i
think finally for whom
simply scientific descriptions of
everything
fills up all the room there is in their
heads and their lives
for me that doesn't mean
well then there has to be the
theological for me it just means that
there are a lot of other things that
aren't scientific that are part of one's
life and one's a way of
understanding
one's own experience telling stories
about it remembering imagining
so i hope that the
way in which i
put these together next time if if you
see it or hear it
will
acknowledge the sort of
objection that you have but also
recognize
the
in
impropriety of a certain kind of
narrow
logical rational
scientific
account of human cognition in its
broadest sense not merely knowledge but
the way in which we operate as
cognizing thinking creatures
i believe that and um it fills a great
deal of my life and the lives of people
that i know very well
but there is something to say it can do
that and it's something else to say it
should do that and it should do that for
everyone
um i i want you to comment on a major
idea that i obtained from john updike
um that of deus absconditus
the fleeing god
from the
personal
intimate immediate god of um
several hundred years ago
we have we now have the god of the big
bang
well um there's a point that is made by
um done it
in breaking the spell
and that is
he thinks that there is
something illegitimate in
the way in which
modern people
in a time of modernity and
intellectual modernity
have made their god increasingly
abstract uh
as he would say so as to retain a belief
and a belief in belief a belief in the
desirability of believing
and he sees this as dishonest
um
i don't have that moral view
of what other people
of that particular thing i certainly
have views of what i consider bad
behavior but i think that people's
effort uh
to
keep connections to their own history
keep connections to a way of life that
they have and yet at the same time
attenuate claims that are made about god
that they know are not acceptable
i don't see that as an objectionable
thing to do i don't condemn that
well thank you all for your
attention and your interest we have some
refreshments out to join
our speaker and uh
you